[Music]
everybody blade here I'm here with Jason
Munoz Jason Munoz and we are backstage
our sets being constructed over that way
but we took you up into the rafters at
stage 15 and now if you can tell by how
Jay is dressed we're gonna take you
underneath stage 15 that's right into
the bowels either that way at least the
anus of stage 50 too far things all
right what is a clean suit all right
perfect
it's just like mine except a lot cleaner
no I don't like I don't like getting
dirty and I don't like you find space is
that gonna be a problem this is actually
how I put my pants on every morning I
put my shoes on first
I was sweating already
all right oh is this is this gonna be a
problem it's quite oh wow
guys let's go down to the bowels of
stage 15 let's go this place is insanely
creepy what do you do down here as you
can see there's a bevy of wire and cable
yes hung up here we're currently laying
what's the backbone of the studio
meaning all the cables for the cameras
or the video cables the tie lines audio
cables we're running them from the
studio to where well from the control
truck across the road outside oh my gosh
under the studio and all the way to what
will be home base that's crazy so we're
running underneath the stage under there
is under the road yeah that paths of
raising all right man I think we're
ready we're gonna get into it let's do
it okay button up your mask put your big
fat did this could not be less
comfortable oh yeah there's a weird
drawings back here all right what's
going on key see me all right let's go
this is really freaky we're gonna go
that way which way no way what the hell
something might aliens I know that's
freaky all right let's see don't turn
the light on is Christ I think we run
underneath the stage right like it's
right there
do a little bit too fast to get in here
this is a really bad idea for a video oh
yeah hey Blair I got a good idea for the
video yeah
put on a jumpsuit and crawl underneath
the stage yeah thanks guys
good idea so glad I did this oh there
goes the crotch yeah oh let's go
that's hard our water tank underneath
our studio what what do you mean he's
like the goodies yeah you know the big
big cove seat with the pirate ship yeah
that was shot in this studio really
awesome
where are you going so glad I came all
the way down here to see this piece of
concrete underneath the stage that's
good it's a little bit of history right
there yeah I've been hanging underneath
the underneath the studio so we can fly
our cables and they don't have to lay in
this boat dust the reason why you're
doing all this and so you're bringing a
TD to the people so that comes from the
cameras we shoot Conan and the fun even
the celebrities the signal goes through
the camera it comes down these wires to
over these J hooks
right here right all the way back down
there all the way back across the street
it goes in our control room get recorded
goes the tape we put in the laughs and
then we send it out to you people at
home so when you're watching the show
starting November 8th think about the
fact that everything you're seeing is
coming down through here because of my
man Jason moon yes put it up right here
brother now I think we gotta commemorate
this event but where's the place we can
mark
oh yeah looking good oh yeah my name in
there oh I've done absolutely nothing
but I'm still marking my name check this
out right here now people think we're
married
[Laughter]
okay alright see you guys later
I gotta go beasts are you sure